[Musique]
tous
ce jardin n'est pas tout
[Musique]
ces rires
pas nous
mais
chan
[Musique]
trois ans
il est gelé ça vire au soir ça s'est
bien passé ton est en boîte
quand romain métier c'est trop facile
enfin je crois que je m'en suis sorti
quand même c'est formidable dit c'est
justement du ballon mais je sais pas que
j'ai mis l'argent parce que j'ai été à
la boutique ensuite un art quand il m'a
demandé une sucette alors survenues j'ai
mis l'argent sur leurs bords et pied
alors à ce moment là parce que c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle julie sait
que c'est très gentil de nous avaient à
remplacer sabrina et moi enfin en gros
tout s'est bien passé oui très bien mais
tu sais que je n'ai toujours pas vu
arriver quasi murs et droit l'ont déçu
que signerait pas là
en fait la queue dès 1000 à bonjour ça
va
qu'est-ce que vous êtes là ça donne
l'idée de faire un jeu s'est pas vu
quasiment non tu as fait rien alors je
recherchais et je vous le dis je lis wii
tm garde mes bouquins est plein et tu
crois pas qu'il condamnait qu'on essaie
de chercher l'argent parce que je
voudrais surtout pas que tu crois que
julie julie julie je vis je t'en prie
c'est pas grave
aucune importance quelle ville
c'était vraiment chouette une écoute
qu'est ce que c'est un joli bonjour je
suis bien content de te voir si ces gaz
inerte et formidable nigériane dans ton
petit numéro là je le pense aussi à moi
plus encore
merci merci à kazimiya ça y est ça y est
ça y est j'ai trouvé mon jeu on va faire
une comptine êtes d'accord
vous jouez avec nous casimir ont fait
une grosse chic alors j'adore les
comptes il a décrété mais c'est la
musique
ouais t'as pas la carte ap ap
casimir avant la musique
on s'occupe des paroles d'accord mais on
appelle les enfants les enfants y en a
quelques uns viennent avec moi pas tout
ça parce que vous êtes beaucoup 3
vendredi
est-ce que je peux me réjouir avec vous
parce qu'il passait son temps à chercher
l'argent c'est pas qu'on va jouer coûte
julie pour la dernière fois je dis que
l'argent on verra ça tout à l'heure on
le retrouvera voiture blindée papier et
un crayon
et j'adapte ou alors je vous expliquer
ce que c'est une comptine exécuté bien
karim et on m'écoute
vous connaissez un deux trois nous irons
au bois quatre cinq six pays à des
cerises connaissez ça là on va y jouer
en partant de 1 jusqu'à 10 et cette
comptine s'appellera si j'étais zen si
on est deux dire si j'étais zain vous me
donnez un nom qui rime avec un après
avec deux trois quatre cinq six
spéciales cetera c'est compris
julie tu attendes la tourette d'une
autre tout et après du nous le dira bon
alors commencer si j'étais un filet pour
le sentir et le thème art oui c'est bien
un point si j'étais jeune je sentirai le
docteur c'est bon si j'étais 2
jean-françois suis gt2 je mangerai 2e
arrêt voilà si on était trois sangliers
droit ce n'était froid carole alors si
on était 3 par exemple on enchaîne une
loi sur les 3 on mangera des noix
parfaitement sûr et si on était quatre
casimir maintenant on était quatre ans
ferait du théâtre si on était quatre aux
frais du théâtre 4 si on était 5
nathalie j'en étais 500 et essayent
julie tu as une idée on chanterait une
complète comme chanterait une complète
voilà si on était cinq ans chantera une
complète si on était six carole cyr a
qui trouvent à vous le dites je dit
carole vas-y fais des plans de sortie à
manger des saucisses à les cracks
est ce qu'il est mais si on était six
homogène et saucisses si on était
certain si on était sept
on mangera les fruits non ça
n'appartient pas un visionnaire dessin
et bien on mangeait tout ça dans une
assiette un vaisseau 6e le leader un
film que ce qu'on avait vu si on était
huit ou chercher au motion 18
si on était neuf calmez vous nous
écoutez monsieur je cherche du feu sur
l'homme recherché sur les chenilles
casimir gens alors j'en étais nord je
lis tu as une idée pour s'habiller tout
en off on sabre irait tout un oeuf ouais
ouais
alors maintenant le dernier vous
précipiter là le premier qui me répond
si on était dix huit et dix non c'est
pas beau ça
ce fait moi je trouvais casimir sur les
métiers et pis on en serait le twist au
hasard c'est un bien très bien casimir
bon que ça c'est peut-être
l'approximatif un wet mais enfin ça fait
rien ça passe quand même et vos cheveux
vous avez fait aussi une comptine
parfait où la lyre et après en attendant
julie nouissel convient de faire rédiger
dit si je suis je sens le tas si on est
deux je mange des oeufs
si on est trois on manque des lois si on
les quatre ophélie p/apw si on est cinq
ont chanté une conclave si on insiste
roger saulnier viande la revanche des
assiettes s'ils ont des huit en ange de
8g on est neuf
vos khalifes qui tombe là si on est dix
dans son giron les 1er 2
[Musique]